mi dice ciccio che e c'è questo sito che
ti permette di ascoltare effetti sonori
dei videogiochi e tour dall effetto
sonoro devi riconoscere videogioco tipo
sarabanda di contrabbando proviamo con
questa cosa perché anch'io faccio ma
posso chiedere aiuto del pubblico si è
poi la mi sembrate tipo l'enterprise
stiamo volando
cross è pronto ai vari sforamenti l'aria
in questo tool e susine pazzo a questo
suono e
prima l'inizio napoli no cash stringer
presidentino il quattro senza cedere mai
così non vedono bellissimo il titolo di
madonna
questo è il meraviglioso world of
warcraft mi ha fatto perdere penso tutto
ragazze due su due
sarà mica
super 8
questo sei tu quando hai fame
lo scotto un indizio grande saga no non
lo so ragazzi elder scroll e di elder
scrolls monroe uguale a morro bravo
chiude un poker nel suolo
zoom
no non lo so è una grande saga anche
questo teheran teheran
no non lo so io però è uno di questi
come un career però qua
conosco bene ricchi ragazzi già una star
grazie
a scuola sono uscito così quando career
e prepara di brooke bailey
questo lo conosci a memoria
[Musica]
è uno che sta morendo call of duty
al in isole show
cosa ricordato che stava una fattoria
per un po bravo bravo hardware fuqua lo
voglio a quale voglio posso dirlo che lo
voglio si fa lo voglio anch'io vediamo
[Risate]
che cappè ragazza a
quanto si
sa mai perché non sto giocando adesso te
lo giuro lo sto giocando adesso per
quello sapevo che non avrei mai
indovinato
[Musica]
tutte le volte che non ho preso la
patente che mi dicevano sei stato
bocciato schiaccia schiaccia ogni volta
devo sbagliare o fare un video una cosa
inviava il video il minutaggio degli
errore e mi mandava lo screen di dark
souls costretto sei morto
[Risate]
lì fallo
lago grazie non lo so a ramallah è una
cosa che riguarda il tempo un blocco il
tempo erano 62 sì però non va indietro
semplicemente presentato prince of
persia le sabbie del tempo propizio max
payne sì posso farti vedere
nell'immagine il protagonista del gioco
va
bene
ciccio payne
perché ci
fece armi
giornata non lo so
ma patella malati e le sue
[Musica]
quindi si parla di minecraft
no
cambiamento di messina spetta per tre
nomi mi dice che mi dice qualcosa
adesso vi do un gioco che tu uscire
fuori di testa bravo tu e verrà qui ad
abbracciare ct bike rocket league
[Musica]
grazie facciamo sentire comunque
l'effetto sonoro beh era nera ovvio
dirlo
kk animal crossing
bravissimo ragazzo queste kk bubblegum
ciò anche la canzone pensa d'erba ebro
il suo disaccordo silent hill con me
tali casi si quando privi conosci i
piccoli
a tiziano andrea è bellina campionato
proprio sta frase dai ragazzi segreti io
farei una carrellata dei suoi mancanti
etilico se ne ha detto qualcuno
lo so next buoni
secondo me ma il cras bachmann
super mario kart
questo è quel gioco del capo della bella
dell'oca me lo
ricordavo state le
dei bravissimi a
non si vedrà mai blue book a crash
bandicoot
[Musica]
isaac e mi ricordava qualcosa dice
minchia cup ed una dedizione dei ragazzi
questo era questione dominate blu vabbè
se serve una trentina in finale è sul
bellissimo avrei voluto continuare
all'infinito questo diciamo che era un
po un test per vedere come funziona lo
studio c'era tutto il resto però
bellissimo ci ha un prossimo video non
ho più la chiusa quindi meno basta più
porto questo che con quella roba costa
arrivederci